first thing I want to watch have you
seen dad she at the award show yeah did
you want an award no oh he presented a
Nobel why does he look like a manager in
McDonald's yep
got your orders but everyone got their
McDonald's look at the awkward Oh what's
a so many awkward middle-aged white
people it must be tough because
literally I love the fact that were dead
she got his platform he took on the big
boys where's to americaine yeah you
[__] illegally streamed our [__]
fight you pretties you are about the
best videos you owe us money I love that
but because these huge companies they're
never in a place for a youtuber to
action how about them yeah I [__]
love that he did that right reigning in
being the guy is literally already on
his way to collect the award from that
big game it's a joke
give miss free fries if you are the ace
Sports Award managers that's what you
get for inviting Deji you should have
done your [__] research
[Applause]
[Music]
literally look at the awkwardness as
blizzard warm past Epic Games alright
and it's not like he's made any mistake
oh please why hasn't he gone in subject
he's so good he's like was it a little
dead jeez just mugged you off so badly
Wow he's actually pretty good dog
he says she all right he's got that he's
light on his feet basically he's like an
animated scarecrow it's not quite on
time all good right yeah Doosan a song
skit I got really drunk the other day
and I text them have you [__] al what
did you reply he said no me so sorry
about that job but bloody good done so
many good dancing I wouldn't mind
watching a friend of mine oh he is one
of the craziest youtubers you will ever
[__] see right in your life right he's
from Canada right right I just want
everyone to know like on the phone he's
exactly like this his name's Brody and
you're gonna love so I'm a wine tested
he didn't know a lot of wine testing
this one has an earthy consistency he
reminds me of Stephen yeah if you know
how Stephen says things but he's not on
camera there's no holding back with this
kid there's nothing he won't say this
kid just about on the floor he's sure
that that's one of the probably more
pleasant things you see these phone
cases is cute darling [__] so we're
gonna be trying these two wines what is
this this is a mmm was this earthy tones
I don't know he's [__] mad but trust
me if we had X or international he'd be
the first kid I'd say wow this is
nothing they're gonna still know I'm
seen even though I'm beeping it out I'm
not saying I agree with everything he
says but I love how he's just like many
societies he basically just sees however
inaudible it was YouTube channel before
I I'll get I'm not imagining that with
your son imagine that's what you're
coming home what sweetie hey sweetie hey
mom mother I kind of like his energy I
think it's good energy so he's mental I
look crazy
yeah this kid only has six and a half
thousand subs and he's got merged nah
but genuinely I think he could be a
million oh yeah the only problem is his
offensive nature yeah yeah I guess so no
in this Franklin says he's Hugh he's
worse than Logan busy like he's like
Logan on steroids he's worse than like
to me he comes across as more aware of
cygnus 100% where is the other guy he's
very self-aware my father was a KKK
member yes
your perfume smells mediocre he's also
pretty good this guy's Travis's mom I
used to be gay and then my dad touched
me and I realized he's also gay
what no I'm not joking though thank you
thank you I feel kind of sorry for her I
just realized that you have to ask for
consent before you have sex [__]
woman hey she's just not into this
anyway
at the top of her Instagram bio it says
plant-based she's not in the wrong here
he's in the wrong but it's still funny
mm-hmm talk about a tight ass so he
basically sneaks into a parade and right
part of the parade he's not afraid
copyright I'll say that he's in with the
chumps isn't he
he's done well then he's gonna [__]
what is he doing what is he doing
people like someone who's willing to do
anything this is the kind of thing where
you watch it and you feel a little bit
guilty when you watch because you watch
it alone instead of in front of
thousands of people he had an issue
where he released some sex dolls blue
balloons into the sky and the police
claimed that he was an endangerment to
the airplanes and in the area writing
and they arrested him into all his
cameras and everything to shut him down
so show him some love bra DTV oh this is
gonna be fun to react to no but it's
just amazing look at that this is the
California fires for those who don't
know she prank yeah it looks like if
he'll came to the earth like this is
what it would look like I mean people
who just drive some people are going to
be super cautious or some weird reason
this woman is a renegade she got through
it though throughout all of it out done
move she's out doesn't realize back of
the cars I'm fine
some web reason I saw this and I thought
of you see your style isn't that show
you know what she's short but Dom night
show movie so what you're seeing there
is a regular kid who puts oil into his
muscles
he's not getting any functional strength
he's not getting anything from there's
not building real muscle tissue what
he's doing is he's expanding the muscles
just making it look like he's strong in
the same way that Kim Kardashian you can
tell she's never a real back side
because her legs look he's just in a Kim
Koo he had Leon yeah that's it and just
like Kim K and a lot of these girls who
go for buttock augmentation
he's been [__] by Kanye West no you
can die from the sort of [__] yeah you
know I'm saying yeah yeah play silly
Russian music to make him look silly so
a traditional Russian unions don't need
Russian music to do that he already
looked yeah look at those legs saw yeah
literally my [__] is thicker than his
legs Mon [__] me he's just looking at
himself being like I just need to do
something to make myself not the normal
kid can I just say we make fun of some
people on this show this guy clearly has
mental health problems well they call it
bigger a CEO basically correct yeah well
it's been coined in the bodybuilding
industry when you think you're not big
but you're
like it's ridiculous yeah they also just
they're so bruised and horrible I don't
know how his arms haven't just exploded
yeah and that's happened before have you
ever try masuleh eat no I do remember
when we spoke about this on a previous
podcast where a guy had it where his
arms just yeah do you want to see that
not really
after years of steroid injections Greg's
bicep fought back just need to know am I
gonna see an arm explode in this video I
don't think so right good
I just wanted to know all right when I
got the infection it starts off you get
a bad fever the area gets red it was
like a giant zit in there it was just
loaded with pus why is great videoing
this because he's like that kind of guy
and he wants to be a big deal that's
what a lot of these guys are the
bodybuilding game you try and beef up
and be huge because they want to be a
correct idea if they feel a bit MD do
you than I'm saying my worry is that
Greg's built such an identity around
build being this big guy that when
Greg's not big
what is great well now he's the man who
arms exploded as you can see yeah well
that's not a good name to have you see
the cut when he cut that went in forms a
scar that's a scar I gotta get that
taken care of
[Music]
Greg be self conscious the fact that
you're using a camcorder from 1988 we've
got a little clip sent in by a fan of
all curly I think I've seen this clip I
think I also saved this type on my list
of clips of her Lawrence and Brian to
watch
[Applause]
why they mopping his tongue like
literally women falling over this
[__] is mental he is not a good
dude either some of the [__] I've heard
about this guy like he has a cult and
women just bark like [__] dogs around
this guy whatever he wants them to do is
this sometimes what you wake up to in
your dreams you wake up and you're going
I'm the churchyard here I'm the
churchyard it and all these women knows
what matter
I mean she's literally got her hands on
his crotch thing he's doing this it's
not her fault what her hand is something
to slip it yeah well no he's gone to the
front of the stage he's put his dick
there and then drilled what I love right
you went to a you went to a funeral once
for an RAF veteran yeah and the god
bless the priest a totally unaware of
all Kelly's nature yeah I believe I can
fly in an 88 year old man's funeral sad
no she's she's doing everything two
touches - look he's got this is Mezger
that smile that smile Oh what are you
doing girl she squeezed the tip she
squeezed the tip yeah be touching my
dick I'm angry with you now he literally
was groping him for a good [__] in two
minutes before he was like that's
because our Kelly's lost all sensation
below the waist of your hood of Lil's
are
price out of sight in my whole guide
salad right oh [__] yeah kids like this
got bullied in school when I was at
school you know I mean what's happening
they're becoming rappers no they're not
that's not a rapper that's that she's
just a man saying things he's it she's
going I've got a car she's got a car
he's got a car we all have cars like
that's a wrap the risk of sounding like
you know a [__] in my dear mm like I
love YouTube don't get me wrong but like
you hutted pay your dues in the music
industry and prove that you had some
talent and nor do i got a record deal in
order to make a music video in order to
get that chance now like you could just
be a little mumble rapper like [__] and
do a little video and boom it's out
there that's it 240 million views
you're a star the video is chill like it
it's quite a relaxing torn away yeah but
there's nothing special about this
anyone can shoot this up as if I got a
rappin thing as though that I'm on a
table my mouth Mabel it just doesn't
make any sense
Tony Robbins for those who don't know
he's a motivational speaker who's but
lots of businesses over the years he is
known for saving people's jobs marriages
he's a life coach
basically he's one of those [__]
artists who thinks he knows everything
about everything and he certainly
doesn't know some [__] yeah
but occasionally he comes across as a
self-important deluded [__] yeah good
old Tony Robbins screaming under a
waterfall
it's very very rocky that isn't it this
yeah much a beach there it's not for
paradise there's not a lot of beach
there is it's real it's many rock star
and then you know eventually bought the
resort then I started building it into
the top resort in the country for the
last ten years and thing I've learned
about bullshitters is anything they
achieve in life especially with a guy
like this times that by 10 of what he's
actually gonna pretend it is yeah did
you go for lunch
I'm with 10 lunches you got a car ten of
them I love that before the cameras come
on one of the people at the back was yes
a normal long II yeah was having a visit
vision some [__] like that they
loved it then yeah just say it he
meditates just just what you're doing it
I like that
tomorrow watch this video the more I
think I can you Tony Nava genuinely he
is who you would be if you were rich
yeah totally yeah yeah another hangout
area that we really love I got out
outdoor beds everywhere got the other
place I'm gonna take you it's been my
favorite which is my upstairs fat giant
bed bits here that's covered that's an
outdoor bed make a business for outdoor
beds Tony because I feel like you're
born to sell them all Tony houses out
his house which we have here and outdoor
bed what should we cook in the outdoor
bed outdoor beds everywhere around the
house do I love the fact that he's just
dropping in the how much he loves his
wife they just cut me because she's
watching over the direct the shoulder
like yeah don't you get any [__]
ideas with all these outdoor beds I just
got one outdoor wife yeah and this is my
indoor wife tell you what a
braggadocious [__] is and how much he
needs there's no way he's just settle
for one woman have you actually watch
one of them dissolve Tony have you
watched one or are you just something
[__] balls that you think are
actually fish food but in turn someone
in the area just saw them and saw this
[__] stupid prick I'll tell them the
fish food is me work encompasses the
fish are out there [__] choking on
[__] golf balls in space dissolve at
all I want I want to show you how he got
this money after we we get over this bit
was it
outdoor beds punt we've got the putz
cover that nobody is that bad outdoors
yeah that's a Tony Robbins you owe me
$50 nutter to your as a TR right there
you'll find that as a one hell of a
quality bed
it's TR 1.2 you got over there after TRX
5 how do you know tremendous it's
outdoors
it's [__] Tony Robbins really become
like an integral part of the community
here my family on both sides they call
me boss all abou which means Big Boss
right that's what he thinks
that's anything Levu in Fijian means
Conte yeah genuinely though he's either
my family on both sides he probably
spends one week of the year here like to
maximum yeah
like Norway is he spending all [__]
you like yeah we've got to say bye to
him I thought one week iary [__] by I
a big dick they're like we've just got
to finish this [__] song with this
cutting off and we can go back to
sitting on our [__] arses in our
outdoors bed that he doesn't know we
slip in 90% of the year so people are
gonna wonder how Tony Robbins got all
this money basically he made it from
being in Blackadder in time teams years
of stuttering cured in seven minutes
so Tony Robbins has come in to help this
guy mmm-hmm let's see what he does I
just know loaded look at that haircut
yeah shocking it doesn't matter I mean
Turner not only like the goatee as well
yeah some you think Tony Robbins would
buy a mirror
man thirty years old to live life been
through all kinds of stuff there's a
warrior and you rashad I'm starting to
feel like a warrior three days ago make
the sound of the warrior the first sound
that comes to make the sound in this out
of the way
the warrior does not see better ever on
the warrior this is mental
these kids are sitting downstairs game
Rashaad doing good now he's got a suit
chocolate must it just Americans are mud
on them I'm giving Rashad's
my newest outdoor beds you do realize he
just rehearsed to rehearse and rehearse
that so that you could get through
without sewing he didn't actually hear
you could see even still he was
struggling there so I mean she's my
model ship but it wasn't cured in seven
minutes not at all it was seven years
and let's be completely honest that is
[__] inspirational should we catch up
on some of our old favorites Lords or
you said you discovered the equivalent
of the girls rewatch lustrous as if
you're new here we're making Christian
advice videos on life love and dating so
consider subscribing they're like love
what Jesus did but maybe we can add
something exactly he was divined right
you cannot beat that you can't add to
divine Jesus had the most subs of all
time beauty pie 70 million Jesus would
jump off a cliff ever you only had 70
million followers and that the thing is
you say Jesus was divine that would
actually be one of his favorite
platforms divine I think we've just
discovered a new social media platform
for Christians yeah get in the AppStore
band with the cross on it yeah it's long
across on it you just click it it's just
five second pieces of advice the
elephant in the room here gone is he gay
is she a beard no he was not wanting to
touch her and she wanted to touch him I
don't always just worries me
this is screwing with me Brian
[Applause]
shi-wan those people you know people who
really want a singing career any
opportunity you won't meet Beyonce and
Beyonce goes no I meet you yeah I've met
girls before who really believe they're
gonna make it and then they start
singing around you and it's the worst
bit is when you're like oh [__]
cheeseburger average I take quick
Laurens story true the most wanna this
will be this is sort of you know
Lawrence level right I went with my dad
quite a lot on holiday my dad's a single
guy you know as far as I know we go to a
lovely or resort very often in South
Despain beautiful place really nice up
in the mountains drive up there together
a great time one year there's a family
with two teenage girls right I was early
20s at this point right man true what
would you do every night in a resort
some nights it's we've got an act to
come in he's terrible on the guitar
second night karaoke she gets up the
same year old not much of a singer not
much of a singer
we occur there had it up really putting
it putting her back into it I mean
there's seventeen-year-old girl 17-year
old girl loving it
my dad goes up and do a bit of Robbie
knockout rock deejay sure small crowded
gathered at this point they thought
that's what real Robbie Williams come to
south of Spain well yeah because you had
the leopard print pants on I do like the
print pants song you know me with the
floor choking you know they never saw
when she did it that was lovely honey
when I did it crowds going wild the room
want more they want Let Me Entertain You
at this point they want to hear if I can
do angels encore encore they're shouting
she was furious she gets up she does
another Adele song which one I can't
remember it was one of the sad ones mum
and dad a sobbing at this point the
mother is so touched by these words I'm
standing by the bar hold this dad
Let Me Entertain You sure a knockout
that's a reply she goes out knocks
another [__] Adele song out that's
three Adele songs in one night ah
that you'd settled and everyone in the
audience is going just like this no
married no stop now I stopped at that
point I thought not worth it she has to
do a fourth song to prove that she's
still better than me Oh God and you know
who that little girl grew up to be
Lawrence no I don't actually AME
Winehouse and you saw your deal with her
didn't you it was the real winner I love
how we thought Pokemon video gotta bring
the the old Pokemon hot oh why is he
literally dressed like us for this video
why is this man camp Ash a 30 year old
Mun min dressing like a [__] Pokemon
curry this is proof he's gay by the way
sing I'm sorry what we did not need any
more proof the man's game there's no
straight man in this world with a cat
start you is it can I just ask you a
quick question
because I had a tiger statue is that
different I wasn't a ferocious - that is
a little [__] brain is being trained
for this by the Bible the Bible is very
much like Pokemon you know this this
collect things to collect you know yeah
there's different characters it becomes
like it's very much a story is all the
sins got to catch them all
I loved when Jesus met Brock can I just
say to your mother you're a [__]
wizards don't exist peg you're not I'm
saying what making water in Hawaii it
was a drip I've ever heard it although
it's not a cheap trick
it's a [__] cartoons TV show where's
the magic in that the opening song is
pretty good I wouldn't call it magical
he might wanna be the very best like no
one ever was magical just good it makes
me feel things can we bring up the
question it's the dad bring out the
crazy and Christian girl to find found
it most girls dream of finding true love
someday the fairy tales be watched as
little girls made from yet seem easy why
are they always in such white it's like
they're in heaven yeah that's what
they're trying to put across does heaven
have a good upload speed pretty good
wife I've heard yeah yeah we're older
and reality his love isn't as easy as
Hollywood made it look and maybe some of
the other things you being taught on
[__] true either
did you ever connect the rest of those
dots woman all the stories we were told
were in truth
who'd a thunk it but guess what the love
and romance bits weren't true the talk
in sleep no that was true Hollywood is
not claiming to have definitive truth
Hollywood is not going this is how life
is I love the fact that they saying
Hollywood's fake well this is the fake
as [__] I've ever seen in my life
she's getting [__] no character
progression no I want to see how this is
changing her that's right okay and also
30 years of not [__] it can never
live up to what she's thinking it's
going to be well maybe it will I mean I
think [__] sex is great book you
think [__] sex is great or sex is
great all that stuff that I wished I
would have gotten done the fact that
she's avoiding talking about any of the
reality that speaks volumes to me the
fact that they're dancing around the
houses says that the reality wasn't that
fun or is it also showing they need to
stretch this to 10-minute time an abuse
the Camus thing they've ever been to can
do much of them imagine that what have
we organized for tonight well we're
gonna play Jenga I'm just wondering if
you got a male stripper and she just
went for [__] went crazy Oh a man who
puts his clothes on in the house
it's really getting to study God's
design for sex
purities oh there a footman Kama Sutra
written by Jesus yes me hold on a sec
did spit on your hand give it a rub that
should hold Mars if we follow these IPRs
constructions for [__] we will have a
great time honey she asked her the
question how was your honeymoon yeah
let's see how long it takes her just to
answer this question yes look says a
million [__] things to me a million
things honeymoon doesn't know what she's
being us how am I gonna package this
what a [__] I'm about the same
raisins I don't go honeymoon do you know
what I mean I actually loved I think
that's because of the intentionality of
getting and if I spinning wisdom and
talking to a lot of different people
beforehand getting those mixed reviews
but then realizing like oh we can do a
lot with our mindsets and the choices
that we make going into our honeymoon so
I had a good time or you didn't [__]
I've never seen a more blatant lie in my
life when you go honey
I actually had a great time because the
intention Ally and the Whizzer know you
have you have a good time you don't need
to justify or rationalize it in this way
this woman had a miserable [__] time
and I can tell how was your honeymoon
I think the wisdom was my favorite part
thirty years down the road
remember honeymoon we just saw you enjoy
about it probably the wisdom yeah
there's no way with an audience like
that that people higher up in the church
are not using them as [__] puppets
one thing I do in busy you can imagine
is them walking into their local church
and pastors seen the video at this point
he's he's a little pissed if I'm honest
and he doesn't get the her first goal
he's cleaning the plane in the glass
she walks in is quiet they're sort of
shards of light coming through the big
windows in the church and use guys saw
the video Christian think you're a good
deer think you're able to tell my flock
what to do
you better start toeing the line fish
food reviewer how can you lose on the
YouTube you know I keep it and you know
why because I don't imply that moved yes
if you follow my Facebook page I guess
what we called me making a cooking with
a quick 10 mins video I'm gonna be
baking those soon I do love how he was
planning the thinness
I thought the Thin Mints was just the
thing off the top of his head no I love
that can we have that in the sub meal
haha video I just love that I love this
guy
butters literally didn't need this huh
didn't need this update hi guys hey I'm
doing a Thin Mints video soon I'm gonna
have some chicken fries so there's my
update like a late night trip it's so
good is that the same as the UK what
similar it looks a little more doughy
yeah yeah I'm learning and it goes
sounded crunchy I'll be getting another
body or will he comment that's the real
cliffhanger I think we're gonna get
another bite if I'm honest I also feel
that he looks around like an animal
guarding its young when he eats and we
got the next bite yeah we got the bug
bite number two based on this noise do
you think he likes it or doesn't like
him
I think well I think we're going for a
bye okay
I agree hey what I didn't see him blown
away about it no definitely not blown
away there's the beginnings of a frown
on there's a be good I think
slight disappointment yeah yeah I felt
ever so slightly yeah
it was just a good like a good apple pie
though cinnamon what is it with his kind
see he loves is his taste buds hone in
on the cinnamon and just go
that's a cinnamon apple pie filling is
very watery watery
I don't really like oh my god does
reviews on the YouTube and he doesn't
like McDonald's apple pies he's not a
basically a real real shot to this
doesn't love a pie
I think he's wrestling with his
conscience right now there's a real he's
torn internally here he's like I love
apple pie but I don't like this one he's
also how do I rush analyze this his mind
is working up a reason how do I let
Apple Pie as a concept down he feels
like he's betrayed up exactly as a real
relationship there there's a bond there
yeah and now he's turning his back on it
yeah a bond felt over years hopefully
sleep at night no we don't know well
probably the back of a car he's even
paused and I'd say that's actually a
classic will any style or it will if I'm
there there will be proud as well early
before we learn new German spec this
nine months before we learn QA so to do
two of these videos Oh mr. popular if
you were a potato how would you be
cooked and why he'd be mush
there's no dough or a hash brown what
would you buy dambulla what would you be
if I was potato yeah I think that'd be
mush creamy much yeah oh yeah I do read
the comments I got a kick out of it I
you know I sit there I shake my head I
say what I was wrong with these people
but hey thanks for watching guys I love
this kids be my brother he's reviewing
the food he can just find a mouse like
there was six of them to start with and
he thought yeah the other review of
these at some point and then next thing
you know he's
any other global supers are just going I
don't know how long they've been in
there but I think I'm gonna get all
these down and then let's see where we
go from there he's looking for the
[__] self I did he found these in the
closet and he doesn't know how long
they've been in there [__] it we'll do
it live okay bill o'reilly approached
real crazy kids cakes okay we're taking
a bite now was he a double biter back in
the day or did he realize we'd give him
the time to be able to do that probably
wasn't watching his retention no I'll
put it down if he picks up like oh oh oh
Hobbit come here replay hobbitses don't
like me his face goes hate it and then
it goes love it watch it watch how it
goes
look hate it who don't like that taste
the bin after - yeah oh my oh this thing
was probably ten years old if you want
more if you want us to watch any of your
favorite videos anything you want us to
talk about because isn't just reactions
and we're talking about whatever you
want
send us the newsletter out the world
whatever you yeah what I want to know
our job for what I want to see is
instead of waiting for Brian to tweet it
tweet at us so we can then put it in a
little annoying these things become
lists on our phones so adult with no I
mean you could help me with a list on my
phone me help you yeah alright if you
haven't already liked the video
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you later